Everyone knows that one fan's trash is another
fan's treasure, and even the worst moments
in film history can serve a purpose.
So maybe that's why these deleted scenes are
so fascinating — because they bear such
a hilarious and terrifying reminder of how
easily one scene could destroy a whole movie.
The Star Wars prequels are pretty much the
definition of a mixed bag.
On the one hand, the visuals are often stunning,
they have no shortage of bold ideas, and the
lightsaber duels are nothing short of spectacular.
On the other hand…
But this truly baffling deleted scene from
Revenge of the Sith is a terrifying reminder
that, as bad as the prequels could be at times,
they could have been so much worse.
The scene takes place after Anakin and Obi
Wan board General Grievous' ship to rescue
the kidnapped Chancellor Palpatine.
The two Jedi are unsure of which way to go,
so they contact everyone's favorite droid,
R2D2, for directions.
But they're stumped — because their communicator
can't translate his beeps and bops into actual
words.
And then this happens:
"I'm pretty sure that beep is down.
“I sense Count Dooku is above us.”
“Oh yes, yes you’re right beep is up."
It goes without saying that this is the only
time we've ever seen a human do that in Star
Wars.
The moment is played for laughs and it is
kind of weirdly charming, but it also makes
absolutely zero sense and completely breaks
the reality of the film.
Even though it's probably a good thing that
this clip was unearthed and put on the internet
— so that everyone can marvel at how gloriously
dumb it is — it's probably also a good thing
that it didn't actually make it into Star
Wars canon.
Back to the Future has gone down in history
as a classic movie for good reason.
Not only does it succeed at being a thrilling
sci-fi adventure story and a hilarious comedy
at the same time, but it also has a genuinely
good heart — and not many movies can say
all that.
But there are certain elements of the film
that haven't aged well, and undermine how
sweet the rest of it is.
In particular, Back to the Future isn't great
in terms of its portrayal of gender and sexuality.
It's one thing for Biff to be a predator — that's
obviously terrible, but he is at least clearly
a villain.
It's quite another thing, however, that the
theoretically adorable young George McFly's
horrifying hobby of spying on undressing women
is played for laughs.
As if that wasn't enough, the film had an
additional cringe-worthy deleted scene that
might have ruined the characters of Doc Brown
and Marty McFly if the filmmakers had left
it in.
In this scene, as Doc Brown attempts to get
Marty ready for his fake date with his mother,
Doc makes a less-than-stellar comment which
really does deserve to be left in the past.
"I just don't know if I can go through with
it, hitting on her.
Nobody said anything about hitting her, you’re
just gonna take a few liberties with her."
Then after that, Marty worries out loud how
putting moves on his mom might turn him gay.
Just be glad we ended up in the timeline where
this horrible scene was erased from existence.
In The Hobbit: An Unexpected Journey, Bilbo
and his dwarvish companions encounter a series
of difficult trials on their journey to slay
the dragon Smaug.
One of the most difficult spots in which these
heroes find themselves comes when they're
captured by goblins in the mountains.
As dire as things seem for them in the finished
movie, there was a deleted scene in which
the king of the goblins forces the dwarves
to endure a form of torture that was deemed
too cruel and unusual to depict on screen...
a goblin musical number.
The song is called "Down in Goblin Town,"
and there's no way to sugarcoat this: it's
terrible.
You could argue that it's supposed to be bad.
“It’s one of my own compositions.”
"That's not a song.
It's an abomination!"
It's based on an intentionally atonal song
from the original book, and does a good job
of characterizing the goblins as weird little
monsters and their king as a self-important
diva who doesn't care for the well-being of
his captive audience.
But that doesn't make it okay to be bad.
It's also two full minutes long, and nothing
actually happens during those two minutes
that's relevant to the plot.
In a movie that's already almost three hours
long, this scene is almost insultingly superfluous.
Of course, as seems inevitable with any Peter
Jackson Tolkien adaptation, the scene was
later re-inserted into the film as part of
an extended version.
Given that most of the cast of the original
Ghostbusters were already established comedians
who were veterans of Saturday Night Live,
it's no surprise that a decent portion of
the dialogue was improvised over the course
of filming.
But director Ivan Reitman clearly wasn't sure
just how absurd the movie's comedy should
be.
Among the failed comedic experiments that
he was toying around with was one particular
subplot that was, in retrospect, gloriously
ill-conceived.
In the book Making Ghostbusters, Reitman explains
that he had planned to have Bill Murray and
Dan Aykroyd play dual roles, not only as the
Ghostbusters Peter Venkman and Ray Stantz,
but also a pair of homeless men named Bojay
and Coombs that were supposed to serve as
a kind of mundane counterpoint to the otherwise
world-ending action.
"Run, get out of the way! Rush rush rush,
always rushing."
Rather than grounding the movie, however,
Reitman immediately knew upon watching Murray
and Aykroyd on film that focusing on two side
characters who were inexplicably played by
the lead actors would have the completely
opposite effect.
However, these characters were present in
the novelization of the film, probably because
book characters can't suffer from weird casting.
Ridley Scott's 1979 film Alien is beloved
as not only a work of thought-provoking science
fiction, but also a tremendously spooky horror
film.
Along with Jaws, Alien is famous for solidifying
the conventional wisdom among horror movie
aficionados that the less of the monster you
see, the better.
There was, however, a scene deleted from the
middle of Alien that violated this sacred
tenet of filmmaking, and proved just how quickly
scary can become silly if a movie shows too
much too soon.
In this scene, while trying to escape the
ship, Lambert stumbles upon the alien sitting
on the ground.
She stares at it for a moment, paralyzed with
fear, before the alien… kinda just crab-walks
over to her.
It's probably supposed to be tense, but from
the way the scene is framed and paced, it
ends up being totally ridiculous — and not
even remotely scary.
And as cool the effects were in Alien, this
scene is a reminder that terrifying creatures
look way better in quick glimpses, allowing
your mind can fill in the details.
When you have the chance to see the alien's
entire body for a long period of time in a
well-lit room, it quickly becomes very clear
you're just looking at a guy in a rubber suit.
The setting of Who Framed Roger Rabbit seems
absurd at first glance, because it is: a film
noir version of Los Angeles in which real
people live alongside cartoons as separate
social classes.
Despite this strange premise, the worldbuilding
ends up being remarkably consistent, and it's
pretty easy to get your head around it once
the story gets going.
But that might not have been the case if one
sanity-shattering scene had made it through
the final edit.
After being captured by the villains, protagonist
Eddie Valiant finds that his head has been
trapped inside a cartoon pig head that seems
to be at least partially alive.
"Oh, God!
OH!"
After freaking out for a moment, Eddie escapes
from his cartoon confinement in an equally
cartoon-like way.
Relative to all the other weird gags in this
movie, this one is much harder to understand,
largely because it doesn't seem to be based
on anything from pre-existing cartoon convention.
Was the pig head once a part of larger organism
that was beheaded?
Or did the bad guys somehow create a sentient
severed pig head from nothing?
Did Eddie kill the creature when he washed
it down the drain?
There's no way to answer these questions without
getting into some really strange existential
territory.
Perhaps the wildest thing about this scene
is that, even with hindsight, director Robert
Zemeckis doesn't seem to think it was all
that weird.
the only reason he cut it was because it slowed
down the movie.
Released during the same summer as Iron Man,
Hancock is something of a forgotten oddity,
from a time before the MCU had redefined superhero
movies.
It stars Will Smith and Charlize Theron, and
has a script co-written by Vince Gilligan,
who later went on to create Breaking Bad.
Although the film only got mixed reviews when
it came out, no one could fault it for lacking
ambition.
It was a bold deconstruction of superhero
conventions, with no costumes, codenames,
or explosions, aiming to be more of a comedy/drama
than a nonstop action movie.
Nevertheless, one deleted scene did feature
an explosion of sorts.
During this scene, the depressed alcoholic
superhero Hancock is having a casual fling
with a woman he doesn't really know, fooling
around with her on the couch in his mobile
home.
Before things go further, however, he tries
to warn her about some of the side-effects
that may occur during their impending encounter.
"Start climbing the mountaintop you know.
You’re gonna need to be as far away from
that as possible."
Unfortunately, she's far too eager to heed
his warnings.
So she's thrown across the room while Hancock
recovers.
Considering the scene is nothing more than
a long set up to a silly joke, it probably
deserved to be left on the cutting room floor.
Although the Terminator films are generally
pretty grim, they're not afraid of getting
a little goofy every once in while.
But one scene deleted from Terminator 3: Rise
of the Machines might have taken things a
little too far.
The scene depicts a promotional video for
"Cyber Research Systems," the company that
developed the original Terminators.
In case you don't remember, Terminators are
killer robots from the future, many of whom
are designed to look and sound like Arnold
Schwarzenegger.
And this video introduces its audience to
the human whose likeness was used as the base
for these robots: Chief Master Sergeant William
Candy, who's voiced by Samuel L. Jackson.
"It is now within our power to make war safe."
The real icing on the cake, however, is when
one of the politicians watching the video
complains about Candy's accent.
"I don't know about that accent.
“We can fix it."
The whole affair is completely unnecessary,
thoroughly dumb, and utterly delightful.
Even though it was cut, many Terminator fans
have accepted this wonderfully weird scene
as canon, and William Candy has his own entry
on the Terminator Wiki.
James Cameron's 1997 blockbuster hit film
Titanic is no stranger to the concept of dramatic
irony.
"So this is the ship they say is unsinkable.”
“God himself could not sink this ship."
This concept works pretty well for Titanic,
however, considering it's clear from the beginning
how things are going to end.
In case you forgot your high school lit, dramatic
irony is a literary device in which the audience
has more knowledge of the events of a story
than the characters do, which lends these
character's words an additional layer of meaning
they themselves don't understand.
When writing a historical fiction epic like
Titanic, the temptation to write nothing but
jokey lines that wink at the audience must
be overwhelming.
Generally, however, Cameron does a good job
of limiting his use of dramatic irony — save
for one particular instance.
"Hey sonny, how about a little ice?"
Needless to say, Cameron eventually decided
that this, the most dramatic moment of the
film, was not the right time for a really
terrible Dad joke.
Probably a solid decision.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.